times a few Wiley and I'm Matt Cornett
hey I'm Frankie Rodriguez and I'm Julia
Lester and Larry Saperstein and I'm
Darrin a what's up I'm Joshua Bassett
I'm Olivia Rodrigo from high school
musical the musical this series and
we'll be taking a quiz on BuzzFeed that
will tell us which High School Musical
character we are I'm so excited let's do
it first things first
how would your friends describe you shy
ambitious smart caring strong or Royals
I think my friends would say I'm caring
I hope I think I'm gonna go ambitious
I'm gonna say ambitious you're caring
yeah yes yeah I think it's great
beautiful is not an option yes you know
I would say caring
you're pretty caring I would say loyal
I'm gonna do loyal I don't think you're
shot I don't either but I mean you'd be
surprised I mean put me in a room with
some people out I'm gonna say loyal I
think yeah you will I'm sure one of the
things that I value the most
yeah let me say what I'm gonna say
ambitious I pick a classic decom to
watch over and over again smart house
double-teamed the luck of the Irish
Cheetah Girls
cadet Kelly of xenon girl the 21st
century these are some excellent choices
I gotta go with cadet Kelly come on I
gotta go with luck of the Irish Hilary
Duff let's get out of here
hahaha no brainer the luck of the Irish
I love that movie
I think I'm gonna have to go with that
one smart house I remember that in the
back of my brain I think I was a little
young for that movie but I think I got
to go with Cheetah Girls cuz that was
like right around my time yeah literally
all of these I would watch over and over
again I'm just gonna do Cheetah Girls
though because I do watch that I'm gonna
go with cadet Kelly just because even
though I love smart house it scared me
so badly as a kid I literally thought
like my house was gonna turn into that
okay and now everyone has an iPhone
I love Zeenat I always loved xenon I
loved the concept of xenon I thought it
was so fun however smart house was my
favorite of all time Cheetah Girls I
mean is it is it hard I mean they work
Sonic let's just say they just they
started a movement i they do they did
pick an OG high school musical song to
rock out to we're all in this together
breaking free get your head in the game
what I've been looking for bet on it
bop to the top if I'm gonna rock out I'm
gonna rock out to get your head in the
game
no literally I'm just gonna go to the
game that was my persons think why not
I'm gonna say bet on it I could answer
that and declare I mean yeah break and
freeze like there's so much passion yeah
I'm gonna break I feel like pop to the
top is always a great song yeah off to I
don't know whether I should shoes getcha
I bet on it or Bob I was a huge
basketball nerd yeah so getcha was my
damn I think I got to do another Zac
Efron one which is bet on it oh yeah and
I was little I literally learned the
choreography to that and I would look
into my pool that I had and I would
splash it and it was very dramatic and I
probably looked crazy but I loved it I
think I'm gonna obviously choose bet on
it but Bob to the top was a buff as I
say we I think I have to go with Bob the
top you oh okay
cuz come on I mean the ladder oh yeah
was iconic in the whole okay I'm gonna
go stop this up they were great okay I'm
gonna go with bet on it because I always
wanted to splash the water take a
musical instrument guitar piano
Tamborine drums saxophone my voice duh
literally that one so remember the scene
when they gave me a tambourine oh so
they gave me a tambourine they're like
here just use this chamber and we were
like playing as like we're all like
gather around the piano it's in the
trailer actually and like the director
came in she was just like I'm can you
not bang the tambourine it was going so
hard she's like I should go or anything
I mean my voice
okay vocals let them know love no I
think we're both gonna okay yeah I think
we're both gonna go with my voice I will
say truthfully I play a mean tambourine
I think that's a true mark of character
if you can play a mean tambourine you
can do it
literally mmm I can't decide I think I
would go with piano there's something
about piano like I literally fall asleep
to piano music every single night I've
played guitar and I've been saying for
years that I want to play piano still
have yet to do but you're good at guitar
thank you no guitar piano girl I love
piano - everybody same answer pick your
favorite subject in high school
I'm inhibited right now so this is gonna
be fun for me drama science history PE
math or foreign language I loved science
Ireland space science was great the PE I
love sports
yeah I've never done PE I mean I ran but
I never done you eat I think I have to
go with math because when I'm when I'm
like actually on a roll with math I feel
like Einstein like I'm I'm smart i 0 I
do have history I'm drama I got a goat
on an ice age wrong I am prey traumatic
yeah I'm gonna go with drama too because
all of these other ones stressed me out
okay I was a pretty good student in high
school I did all of these things I'm
gonna go with drama let me just be
honest I did not do good in any of these
subjects well I did not like science
because I did not do good in science
history was good AP History
um math you know shake the math foreign
language now who's gonna be not PE I
just running it's just there you're in
high school not able to see I pick a
former Disney star seen through it oh I
know what you're gonna say we got Joe
Jonas Hilary Duff Cole Sprouse and dad
Demi Lovato and Raven Symone excellent
choices we're righty
you guys nailed it I'm gonna go with
Demi Lovato her voice is Taylor to be
able to sing with her like that would
just make me a great singer by
association I feel like I gotta do
Hilary Duff come on guys yeah we know
this by now
yeah at d23 he was walking by and
apparently she said she had a crush and
we were like I mean I'm maybe not
because like I would just be like the
whole time because she's so gorgeous her
voice is amazing I love her I think I'm
gonna go bro out with Jojo I love all
these people I think I'm gonna do Demi
cuz I saw her live I'm gonna have to go
with Johnny to Jojo
oh interesting so with like every guy
that I instantly loved I loved Hilary
Duff oh yeah Hilary doesn't mean Larry
def once and I told her that I had a
crush on her I was going up and then she
went oh okay Hilary Duff imma just put
Demi cuz she was the last song I heard
uh I'm not sorry grab a bite to eat from
the cafeteria
carrot sticks tater tots jello pizza
cookies Apple I love this one singer
tots
come on I'm jello man jello I love you
laughs I love jello oh it's my favorite
you don't feel like you're eating
anything keep going it's great what I'd
be really pretentious if I chose carrot
sticks like I honestly love carrot
sticks no that's not pretentious they're
six are great mystics anything with
tater tots is there they're iffy because
if you get some soggy tater tots there
are no go but if you get like the nicely
we're kind of entrepreneurs or tater
tots oh yeah
tater tots I'm gonna I'm gonna go with
some talk I'm gonna go to pizza sorry
tater tots
I'm gonna talk I'm annoying I'm a vegan
oh so carrot sticks I hate myself
boy six are good yeah branch I'm a vegan
lastly and the spirit of Martha Cox
which one do you like to do the most
do you hear you do it while I say them
because you're the do you like to pop
lot jam or break I think Jam Jam I mean
Jam okay yeah I'm gonna jam - i'ma say
pop I don't know Jam walk freak
how would you pop I like to jam oh I
like the pop okay would you get I just
Sharpay Evans oh I got Kelsey okay okay
I thought I was gonna get Ryan but I got
start hey I got Sharpie - oh we both got
first this little divas yeah we are the
same we got you wanna say to get this
sure Bolton Wow I'm Mary Calvi axe
you're a little shy but that's because
you have so much talent you don't know
what to do with it all so true you're
not really bad shot like I am in the
first time I met you you just like Here
I am
oh yeah I guess so you're a boss with a
capital B oh you know what you want and
you go for it sure people can talk but
no one is gonna dull your shine or steal
your spotlight damn right oh yeah dang
that is that's real that's good that
just boosted my self-esteem
I always resonated with Sharpay I mean
this girl knows what she wants that is
here right okay it says you're a
natural-born leader and everyone likes
you you're pretty popular on campus but
you use your popularity for good and not
evil I feel like it's totally you I mean
here's the thing I was in theater played
basketball so literally like I was Troy
mm-hmm if we can both be Zac Efron
that's the greatest thing at all you
gave it our all present
[Music]